un enfant noir aux noms célèbres zodwa
mandela petit fils de nelson mandela
noir et blanc dans la même eau alors où
l apartheid
côté jardin des journalistes aux aguets
côté cocktail à public de vieilles dames
faut 100 da facile enfin winnie mandela
accompagné par ses enfants et petits
enfants winnie mandela reçoit l'hommage
d'un bouquet des télévisions étrangères
winnie mandela véritable princesse son
mari descend d'une famille royale winnie
mandela l'indomptable arrêtés
emprisonnés banni aujourd'hui elle
revient d'une visite à son mari
et malgré les risques elle s'adresse à
des journalistes étrangers
il lui est interdit de parler à la
télévision sud-africaine
d'où l'étonnement des indigènes blanc
qui la découvre en vedette dans leurs
hôtels
quatre heures plus tard l'arrestation
elles bravent l'interdiction de revenir
dans sa famille
entre l'hôtel du monde nelson et le
chemin de soweto l'apartheid lui saute à
la figure
[Musique]